[Music]
right she'll just revection grab I'll
take your first spin along the front and
when we get back
I think they've got a male stripper for
you what
what I'll make that last bit up
I want to go to France
[Music]
what are you on about the trip to the
beach is Day Day
really sorry Bernie
you left it too late I couldn't leave
you all on your own unless
you have to
where is he he's disappeared off the
face of the Earth
peace in France bonjour at 90. well he
has done it before only then of course
there was shooting at him so determined
to honor his Fallen comrade the D-Day
veteran made a break for the coast and
it mounted what has now been dubbed
Great Escape
who are these people the Germans oh this
was your Beach
thank you
foreign
[Music]
to every second and every second is
worth clinking to I'm I'm sorry I've
been in the papers I've been on TV
90 year old coffin Dodger
polish the Glorious dead
what a waste
hey
the waste
if you want to honor your friend Bernie
you've spent 70 years loving me I go
anywhere with you we have never wasted
one second of our time together
are you coming to bed
yours or mind